joining me now editor-in-chief of The
Daily wire Ben Shapiro is here welcome
back Ben hey how are you very good thank
you so much for being here
so how much damage does a story like
this do to victims who have bravely come
forward with their own stories of sexual
assault against people like Harvey
Weinstein and Matt Lauer I mean I think
that it does do some damage just because
there are people who actually have
experienced truly terrible things sexual
assault and abuse who may be afraid to
come forward because the reaction to
this story has been so bad but the
reactions that the story should have
been bad so I think this has been a
failure of the me2 movement from the
beginning to make distinctions between
gradations of bad right between being a
jerk on a date like Aziz Ansari
apparently was and Harvey Weinstein
raping people that failure to make
specific radiations has led a lot of
people to say well you know maybe we
ought to give everyone short shrift and
it's also led a lot of women to say I'm
not sure that I want to experience going
under the microscope this way if it
means that everything that I say is
going to be picked apart so again I
think specificity and all things is
useful and it particularly is useful in
situations like this one I think it is
useful as well that's something that I
said from the beginning because I think
some of the accusations that people have
made about Harvey Weinstein that law and
people like Kevin Spacey and louis c.k
there they are incredibly serious and
they speak to a much larger problem do
you think by and large the me2 movement
has been good for this country I think
the media movement has been good for the
country but I think well that what is
really pointed to is the need for a set
of rules that make some sense and so far
I haven't seen a set of rules that make
a lot of sense from people on the Left
who alternatively suggest that consent
is the only standard and then will
suggest that even in areas where it
seems consent has been given that men
are supposed to read the the nonverbal
signals I mean that's the case in this
house he's on sorry case Glenn was
saying that she gave nonverbal cues that
seems to me that being naked in the
guy's apartment and performing sexual
acts on him at least twice is a pretty
solid nonverbal cue that he might take
the wrong way so it's it's it's bizarre
to me that if you're gonna set a certain
standard the only standard is I consent
to be here and do this that you're
somehow going to change that standard
because you feel pressured or awkward
again you got rid of all the traditional
standards and now you bill
this false standard it's place that's
sort of legalistic in nature and it's
not holding
all right so describe the the
progression of the backlash because with
the movement this big that takes down so
many people there is bound to be a
backlash so where do we go from here so
I think it's gonna be a backlash in then
a backlash to the backlash then people
are gonna say we need some due process
here we need some actual objective
allegations that are verifiable or at
least believable right it can't just be
you think something bad happen to you
but there's no way the guy could have
known and then it's his fault right
that's that's been the backlash on Aziz
Ansari and then that's created the third
wave feminist backlash where people say
well no you have to believe all women
right I mean I thought that was the
whole premise here you got to believe
anything a woman says no matter how
subjective no matter whether you think
she gave a signal or she didn't give a
signal otherwise your victim blaming and
that creates another backlash once we
move away from an area where there's
virtual unanimity rape bad sexual abuse
bad and we know what these terms mean
into an area where there's backlash
followed by backlash that does kill the
me2 movement because the entire movement
rests on the assumption that most
Americans are not in favor of evil acts
all right well I am in favor of your
goodness in your intelligence Ben
Shapiro thank you very much for sharing
some time thanks a lot